good morning Hank it's Tuesday September
22nd 2009 the day that my book Paper
Towns finally comes out in paperback
will he's so excited he got a haircut I
got to get myself one because this is
not a paperback it's just just piece
paper ok so before I talk about Paper
Towns finally coming out in title
appropriate paperback I want to say one
other thing it's been almost a year
since the hardcover of Paper Towns came
out and I first found myself in a Margo
sandwich and Hank when I look back on
that year I will always remember it as
the year that you and the nerdfighters
changed my life your commitment and
organization got Paper Towns on the New
York Times bestseller list you sent me
black Santa's and great white walls of
cow and most of all because of the torta
nerdfighting I got to meet a lot of
nerdfighters and talk about the book
which has been so so fun so now here it
is almost a year later and Paper Towns
is coming out in lots of different
countries and I'm writing a screenplay
for the people who made Juno and it won
the Edgar Award and nerdfighters I want
you to know that none of that would have
happened without you
well actually I might have still won the
Edgar but I wouldn't have been able to
make that what would you do with a Poe
bust video so nerdfighters if you've
read Paper Towns thanks for reading it
thanks for giving it to your friends
thanks for making freaking cakes of the
paperback cover I mean holy stewed Hank
look at that cake whenever they change
the covers of the books I'm always
really nervous although I really like
the Paper Towns paperback cover but
really a new cover is just a new
opportunity for nerdfighters to remind
me how awesome they are like I wasn't
sure if I liked the paperback cover of
an abundance of Katherine's until I saw
this picture and then I was like yes I
liked it very much
so okay thank you to everyone who's read
the book but if you haven't read the
book that's okay now you have a great
opportunity to for one thing Paper Towns
used to cost like $18 and now it only
cost $9.99 now you're probably saying
John I don't want to spend $10 on some
book even if it did win the Edgar Award
that's okay I'm not asking you to spend
$10 I'm asking you to spend $9.99 plus
applicable sales tax so now you may be
wondering okay but how do i buy the
paperback of Paper Towns it's easy you
can either click the link in the sidebar
or you can go to any bookstore in
America which I'm going to show you how
to do right now but
I need to go buy a copy of the Paper
Towns paperback because I don't have one
and I need 15 by Friday when I'm going
to announce the winners of the ten word
challenge contest the only thing you
might want to do before you go to a
bookstore is write a nerdfighter note
nerdfighter notes are of course the
little notes that nerdfighters write to
other nerdfighters or would-be
nerdfighters and then slip into copies
of my books saying like hey if you're
reading this you may be a nerdfighter
don't worry it's a good thing for more
information go to nerdfighters calm best
wishes your name only you don't write
your name you write like whatever your
name is
well you don't write like whatever your
name is you you write ah
and now to the bookstore you can pretty
much go to any bookstore but I'm going
to kids Inc here in Indianapolis because
they have Playmobil so then you go into
the bookstore and you find a paperback
of Paper Towns well in this particular
case I'm going to sign it I don't
recommend that you sign it but I'm going
to I'm actually gonna buy this one so
it's weird if I sign it and then you get
to walk out the door with your brand-new
copy of Paper Towns if for some reason
the book store doesn't have an in stock
yet you can always ask a bookseller to
order it for you
booksellers are nice I promise ok I'm
gonna go work on the Paper Towns
screenplay for a while I'll see you
singing tomorrow I actually I have the
camera on right now let me just say it's
something real quick I just found out
that the editor of Paper Towns Julie
Strauss gable had a beautiful baby girl
Ariel
yeah Ariel